oh god you're not the captain you're
just Jack yeah alright hey captain are
you back captain the captain Pekka
where's our captain Perry Perry over
there he's over right no he's down there
come back
we're driving full speed at the [ __ ]
that the island are you turning out okay
my baby died 1889 he died he died Eddie
died I saw her on a pirate ship whoa
whoa laughs ha ha ha the dr. D was
destroyed yeah we got a long way off
I guess the doctor wasn't in today got a
tight rope like that that's great
yeah well with jokes like that how am I
not driving this boat looks like I don't
even need a ship ok I'm coming with the
place oh my kind of my kind of all right
what the hell oh god right cannon ducks
foot ah Jesus oh [ __ ] hi okay you're
here a Paso writer yeah they went all
the way around
oh they hurt us a lot look [ __ ] all
these hole I'm dirty all the holes in
the back I'm popping oh okay good I'll
get the hole that's the last one we got
it all pumps active when we have one all
of our one pump is a key oh right get
your cup and I got my foot I got what I
got oh I hated reloading apparently Oh
clothes on Jesus level guns what they
killed boy whistles I'm gonna prepare
something
Oh keep pumping keep pumping I got a pun
Wow I've been had yeah I'll be back in
three seconds don't you worry
[ __ ] we're on it flips
[ __ ] matter one down where we
heading Lud let's go back to the battle
let's [ __ ] him up and their mothers
let's go beautiful I retired on them
let's get the pirate we're totally like
a pirate on pirate action with this I
wish if you bush q you don't see how far
ahead we are I'll be back guys I got it
I gotta go bathroom okay I'll be back
okay we'll take over your dough honestly
we're like tied with the top guys on the
entire rest of our
team I'm not weird I'm not tied with
anyone good yeah I mean I am you we're
on a shitty boat though our scores are
getting dragged down but we're we're
tied with all the swag bros oh I didn't
even realize that where the gang go
Montoya is nine hundred points
like a grub I've got like nine hundred
points then you suck it everything got
three points
well that's inaccurate so you do have a
whole other point
oh yeah oh oh I can't read number so
thanks also I had week number so Mick I
got a damage from like with we all died
our one o'clock yes yay did that really
happen or you guys just goofing with me
oh it was what are we hitting the one to
the right oh the one that posts right
right so I can enjoy canons I'm ready
alright loading powder come on a little
closer but don't turn you [ __ ] it's okay
father sales captain can you [ __ ]
turn I really should be actually talking
a voice chat yeah hey if only we could
talk directly to our teammates in
quarters I'm captain card I'm gonna fire
I've tried to pick off their captain
gets it is that all oh wow where's the
hole where's the holy forgot they had
cannons do it's right by my sin body I
just yeah they're just like men it's
just fun to shoot kegs of people they
don't shoot back cool captain don't
battle like this we're losing we're in a
bad spot none are good guys we're good
we're good what do you talk about the
health beverage is good Oh buddy you got
it through the floor right side cannons
load load load I got oh my god am I
going for it boom Oh God
Oh Adam I don't know man I got killed on
this there by their little buddies
exchange service copy we seem to be in a
bit of a pickle see the end of the
situation
oh god we need so many supplies right
now I got a guy here we thinking don't
go behind it saying that I don't know
exactly what I'm doing here I well
they're all somewhat keep floating in
the ceiling here that's nice that's not
a good time all right I've got some left
side
all right I'm loading up come on blowing
up pushing it yes that's a direct fit
yes
all right I'm gonna hit him with this
one yeah I got him as well like good
ship away you're not pleased
[Music]
boi-oi-oi-oi-oing that's the sound of
the [ __ ] the [ __ ] war cry oh
oh god forget round oh good what I did
or disappointment [ __ ] nothing this day
you're raised right use your guns you
deserve they're on board more like
they're on board and wait on the backs
guy this guy's scary ha duck foot time
Oh God okay well I'm here I'm here
take it home fix the hole is the hole
there's the hole there's a hole just get
on the cannons get out the cannons
retaliate rah I gave us a laughing I got
okay
bumpy's guys right there into a little
of the ship man just a little handle
I'll get the sales guys I'll get are you
really not done where the pump was this
whole time Wade yeah when everyone else
was like totally on board with how that
works
oh yeah guy right I realize I was on
board with it
everyone knew Wade you idiot yeah yeah
thank you for rubbing it in
yeah I will make sure everyone knew that
you didn't know that thing that everyone
had known I fell guys guys don't leave
me please
please mark oh come on guys got
somewhere I'm gonna board their ship
you're [ __ ] better I got it don't
worry I got they don't suspect a thing
they also they might
suspect Thompson left me behind going
off the right although a liking us
they're behind us right now yeah they're
behind a summer we try to go for the
company I'm rowdy man wait
might have some here that's a pirate
ship we're shooting it no behind us
right way - okay all right couldn't
board him now that didn't work I know
that but people were still shooting of a
pirate ship
let's try cannon I'm in the ocean Phil
didn't get on either sharks just fire
the left side cannons it'll be fine me
I'm in the ocean was fun it's nice next
oh hi
good job guys I feel like I've been but
I feel part of it I feel like I'm
participating we're gonna [ __ ] run
out of supplies oh no I possible our
ramming oh no raring I'm taking embassy
repairing oh okay
oh no oh no I'm repairing John dead oh
no no me die ed live we can do it March
bring it back oh my go for him I'm going
for him wait a hair [ __ ] dead okay yeah
I responded to normal conditions with
the ship is floating boat came into
effect this is so good I know I barely
see what's happening and it's [ __ ]
intense wait oh you got them all I'm on
our allies pirate ship I don't know what
happened I'm on the wrong ship but I got
here I guess I'm part of their crew now
I'm just on their scene now so I'm just
gonna do my bad beer okay nevermind guys
I I was the only one over there epic
caught a cannonball in the face alright
so off the bow off the front to the left
and to the right are enemies the one in
the middle is yeah HMS swag nice shot
yeah
my man the best time limit reach just
like in real fight so I had to goodness
I got get involved we're encountering
and killing everything oh we might have
to try British not required it's 8 to 12
British pirates right now you guys can
switch teams once you've selected oh
yeah how
if you hit escape I think switching into
option
okay I'm going Brit we can we can all
switch to British alright I'm British I
already shoot one you want to poo for
the oh my it's probably I read it out
loud
let's join poop Oh guys it's full guys
it's full
ah dr. D yeah yeah so nice Oh what's
this afforable hell yeah hell yeah
poop again but no I can't get in poop
ooh I pooped out no there's two spots on
food supply is full there's one small oh
wait it's Harbinger now oh yeah no I
think oh yeah whatever you're all here
we're all here we're here we're here
guys right here it's all good [ __ ]
fun oh my god you can change your side
weapons oh [ __ ] yeah oh that yeah the
Ducks Lord is king bomb smashing hey I'm
anything I'm an Internet blog revolver
okay look out at night our wait weren't
a big boat no we're not wearing a little
though which water whoa whoa sorry that
was my
right that cannons ahoy to Layton
couldn't hit oh sweet Jesus
Oh God Oh commandership ah we seem to be
here we have no walls helping we popping
with a thumping and turning over the
whole thing and then goddamn Island
where the whole old repair Manning the
pirate ship I can
yeah I'm fixing even pyrite yeah
watching web so got a pirate on the
pirate ship
we're going to throw a bomb here we go
oh yeah thank you Bob your auntie ah
[ __ ] I'm not sure he'll drink a
miniscule call they just do a grenade
look out
don't go in there so going there Oh guys
it's Rohan hello we have been there how
I got sold hmm I'm going down that can't
tell notice almost up with this normal
like mini shot I don't know if it's not
an arc to it yeah it's really hard to
judge yeah there's a very small and Eric
to it are they all behind us around aim
here yes we were we were in a bad spot
there they're all like behind us right
now and it's all loaded yeah reload
everyone side right side right side oh
you want to go around front front right
front right don't write an enemy I think
it's going to be a right side for
outside when we catch up is that not a
[ __ ] hit are you serious off that guy
just teleport it is that real it okay
right site I'm coming in like a river
side main and turn little left please
almost got it end going on we'll keep
this you got him I already short all
they're about flame into it well what
that hurt oh I got one of them one
ambulance guys that's the same time
kill those [ __ ] feel yourself feel
yourselves feel yourself a feeling I've
grenades no huge I'm preparing
Oh gonna throw a bomb oh my god I'm like
three inches away
oh right okay no coming right at him
comin right for it
oh no I cut Oh God oh let's I get in and
I'm gonna go get on the way oh my god Oh
like I died that I died real good do
guys who's on fire you gotta go on the
letter I gotta pull yourself out oh no
the whole place my right into water one
right now how many dates not if they're
on our they're on our ship they're on
our ship and how droll Oh [ __ ] what
the hell what the [ __ ] my right rolling
your grace well [ __ ] is happening
growing on it oh god I threw a grenade
on through the hole our Hong Kong's been
wearing down [ __ ]
I am harming guys up yeah hit on their
ship I can't get off there should be a
welcome mat here nope died oh yeah girl
here No Oh gonna be a way you get rope
and throw it cuz it's like a grappling
hook that's the Rope must be oh damn it
resupplying [ __ ] we have a terrible
captain - yeah our captain's an idiot he
doesn't want to go he wanted me to be
captain I mean he doesn't want to be
accepted yeah well he should have
thought about that before he became
captain Oh Bob go Captain Bob we're not
we're not getting [ __ ] per se
all right I'm captaining um we've got
enemies Bob I'm there's a nice ship over
there they would be good
Jedi's you say I you say hmm everyone
has been I I practice now on the episode
that's all I've been doing here
Merrigan comes under family that's
Connery at all fish Sean Connery I'm
gonna try it I'm gonna try and slip in
towards our allies and then and then
we'll engage with them maybe
what was the button to see where people
were cue my good man it looks like an
arrow with a little tail Oh a fast man
with the dick yeah like a key to remove
me from the wheel while the [ __ ]
captain just took over
look that guy we've got to be a way
that's with us no one else to be catch
yeah there's got to be a way to like
really switch
oh that can relinquish his command I
know he can but i'm dumb i should be a
get back we can't like well he I don't
think he ever relinquished this command
is the thing okay front right front
right got it going for it we're gonna
have a broadside coming up depends on
where he goes but maybe we just like oh
I got that pump guy died right cannon so
I can enjoy cannon get him getting ready
alright we're not lined up when I was
right all right all right all right okay
I'm trying to throw a bottle over there
look at what gained upon a bomb jumping
like a goof
okay hit him girl yeah oh that's a lot
of yeah my god we just walked on how
gently no no no okay okay no not to
[ __ ] god we need you [ __ ]
hi I like grenades was a great to the
great everybody whoa
found it oh I killed somebody
god damn right it was there
Boober are you able to talk since Cody
um [ __ ] you Cody lining up a short oh
god I totally wrecked my goddamn cannon
shot ah but I hit him hard with the
whole needs offender of hair sales but
the [ __ ] dick boxes are weird give
anyone the Pumped with anyone on the
pond I got a [ __ ] holes I'm dead
we're sewing foot pump going for the
pump going for the power here oh good
news
oh Jesus I'm yellow okay we're lonely
might be down
oh I just waited 400 Shin man no I'm
still somehow pumping just pump into the
bottom of the ocean I'll get it guys I
think the tactic here is our captain's
not ramming people or an open opposition
it's just generally sucking at getting
our guns on people hey that's all
captain for a few I'm still pumping
according to my screen we're about to
get absolutely shrekt by the Pirates you
don't know that if you look at the
tickets you can see what nah man come on
we're late for this is like golf they
have a hundred and one it is what it's
like all guys written bring visits all
we all suck at it would be would be how
this is like golf god guy like them on
fire wait mark are you on are you hot
hot damn huh what do I need to call the
police or the fireman
ah hmm the Foley the fake police who's
ever green hola hello hmm just Bruno
Mars is gay hmm gross a has come out
right sy Canon or get ahead apparently
nothing we're revving Walker's office
all right ah left my painting blastin
[ __ ] [ __ ] oh [ __ ] I'm going you're
welcome oh ah oh there captain alright
when you do a sheet over there we need
to fix the nose we need to fix the nose
and the holes
oh [ __ ] fire get buckets you talking
about your fire out oh boy
alright I don't know where the lights
are buckets her at the front right we're
good we're good we're good I'm gonna
pump Oh God Oh Oh No
oh geez oh holy [ __ ] we are getting
[ __ ] a lot of homes inside so hard
just fix the holes in pump
I don't think fix every week we lose we
do we've no life
oh oh that's okay we don't know about
if up anomaly one in spirit cane
[Music]